one of our loyal viewers sent in a
question the other day he was asking why
when he creates an empty text document
on his computer does it have a file size
of zero bytes well there's no text in it
so that sort of makes sense but he
realized well actually there's some
information associated with it this
thing's like what's got a file name does
have bigger size it is there's a time
that was created in some where's all
that information stored why does it have
zero bytes and yet we know there's some
information stored alongside it so we
can then demonstrate what this actually
means if we use the computer so let's
just create a simple text document this
documents got nothing in it so let's
save this app to disk and we'll call it
empty dot txt so creating an empty text
file and if we look on our system we can
see that we have created a file called
empty txt with zero bytes in it it's an
empty file there's nothing in there and
if we have a look at all the data that's
in there we try and cap the file there's
nothing in there that's an empty
document just to prove that a real text
document would have some information in
it let's create one that says hello
computer file and save that out we'll
call this is not empty dot txt and if we
look at that one now we see that two
files empty which has got zero by its
associated with it and not empty which
has 21 bytes associated with if we just
look at what's inside not empty we see
that those 21 bytes form the ASCII codes
for hello computer file so we have these
two files ones empty which has nothing
in it and one of them has 21 characters
in it and the line feed at the end for
hello computer file but neither of them
actually have the file name stored in
them they don't have the date there they
don't have how big the file is so where
is all that stored what's going on there
well actually we need to think about
these bits of information is about being
two things we have one bit of
information which is the document in
this case is either empty or it's got
some ASCII characters in it but the
other information isn't really part of
the document it's describing that
document so it's information which tells
us what we want to call the
document how big it is when we edited it
and so on it isn't actually about the
document and the easiest way to think
about that is to think about it if you
rename a document you don't change your
document so if I rename the file not
empty txt to be still not empty dot txt
we've changed the file name but the
files still the same then we've given it
a longer file name so if we hex dump
this one a bytes match between the two
different ones the other thing we have
to think about first is that we have our
document and if we draw that out so we
have computer icon for the document and
we also have alongside that the
information about what we call that in
this case empty txt so this document is
called empty txt and it has a size which
is 0 bytes and it'll have a date we
created it and as we change things about
this as we move it around these
information will change so we might
change the file name so we call it still
empty dot txt we get rid of the old file
name but we haven't actually changed the
document that stayed the same so just as
we think about these things as being
separately we have the name which
describes a document but isn't part of
the document the file system in the
computer does exactly the same so if you
remember back to the videos we did on
how data is stored on a disk and we
divide the disk up into a set of tracks
and we break those tracks up into single
sectors so as well as storing the
documents on the tracks and sectors on
the system even if it's an SSD it's
still emulating a lot of the time this
old system the hard disk tend to use as
well as storing the data we also store a
directory or catalog that represents
where that information is stored I'm
going to use the fat file system as an
example here because it's relatively
straightforward to understand systems
like NTFS x2 etc a ZFS will all use
different variations but they have
similar concepts they use more efficient
ways of representing the catalog so on a
flat file system the directory is really
just a special type of file so there's a
special directory called the root
directory which is the one that the
system knows about where to find but
inside that you'll find entries that
point to other directories and also
point to files and each
those entries in the original flatus
system is made up a 32 bytes of data and
these are stored consecutively averages
so if we had another one it would
immediately follow these 32 bytes so the
first eight bytes for example I used to
store the first part of the filename so
if we had a file name that's called the
empty which is what we usually have the
EMP T Y so that's five counties and we
store the other three being spaces the
next three bytes store the extension so
T X T we don't store the dot so we have
a name padding up two spaces then we
have the extension there we then have
various other flags and so on some of
which tell it whether it's a directory a
special file and so on and then towards
the end we have the size and there's
four bytes which is specify for that
which means you can't have a file bigger
than four gigabytes on a flat file
system and there's also two bytes which
say where the file starts so in this
directory at the beginning of the disk
we have this information which describes
the file most importantly it tells us
where on the disk to find it where it
starts and how big it is now we need to
know how big it is because we can only
allocate a whole number of sectors or
technically we use clusters which is
multiple sectors join together to store
this file so we know where the first one
is and there is another section of the
system which tells you which are the
ones sort of formed together to form a
linked list of the files that we use
we'll go to that in another video or
someone will and so we have the size so
we know exactly where to stop in the
last cluster that we're using so this
case this will be 0 because the file is
empty and we have the name of it stored
here interesting leaves the file 0 you
could say that the star cluster is also
0 so you don't actually have to take up
a whole cluster storing nothing so in
terms of actual disk space this empty
file will stop take up no disk space at
all because it's all the information it
needs is part of the directory now
there's one caveat to that as we said
each of these files take up 32 bytes and
eventually you will fill up the cluster
that is being used to store that
directory when you do that the next file
will need to start using another cluster
and so that will take up another
Heol kilobyte of disk or hole 512 bytes
of disks or whatever is depending on how
the filesystem set up so at some point
you will create a file and we'll use
some displaced let my just depend on how
many other files have got us to whether
the UNIX file takes in his face corner
yes so it depends on exactly so as we
add more files into a directory
more empty files they won't take up any
space and then suddenly you'll add an
empty file and it will take up a whole
kilobyte of space on disk and then
you'll keep adding more and then you
won't take them any extra space then
you'll have another one and you'll take
up a whole kilobyte so you could
theoretically fill up your whole hard
disk with empty files and have no space
on that if you want to try it do so but
don't blame me if you suddenly find your
computer doesn't work often you have to
find some way of deleting the empty
files where your computer probably
wouldn't boot properly and we know one
uses fat these days anyway
he created the empty txt file and didn't
have anything in it and it took up zero
bytes we discussed why education some
space but he also created a rich text
file an RTF document